hey guys this is a video about the
solutions that you guys gave to a puzzle
I posted if you haven't tried to solve
that do that first everyone else well
thank you for all the responses I'll
start this by recapping the puzzle
quickly we have many spies who are in
teams of two if they're caught by the
enemy then they'll each be interrogated
separately for the interrogation there
are three known questions and each spy
is asked just one the first task is to
train your spies so that they do these
three things on average for each
question asked half say yes and half
know if teammates ask the same question
then they must have the same answer and
finally regardless of what question is
asked the teammates only say the same
thing half the time then you have a
second task to show that this third
criteria is silly so let's try and
satisfy the rule that if teammates are
asked the same question they must give
the same answer but remember they can't
communicate with each other after
they're caught so the first Spy can't
tell her partner I got asked question
one and said yes make sure you say yes
if you're asked that question - so they
both have to decide what their answers
will be for each question beforehand
this seems like the only solution and
it's the one that most of you suggested
if I may draw an analogy here suppose
that you have two electrons and someone
tells you that if you measure their
spins in the same direction then you
always get the same value for each ie
they're both up or they're both down in
that direction then the perfectly
reasonable thing to think is they must
have decided whether they'll both be up
or down in that direction beforehand but
let's come back to our puzzles so I can
show you why we've already contradicted
rule number three let's say you've given
each pair their answers to memorize in
any way you want
how often do spies say the same thing if
you've trained one group to always say
yes or always say no they obviously
always say the same thing which isn't so
good the other option is to
yes and one no or vice versa how often
do these guys say the same thing
obviously if they're asked the same
question they're going to agree so now
they need to agree less often if they're
asked different questions to even it out
is that the case let's check say the
first spy is asked question one and the
second is asked question two then they
say the same thing
whereas if he's asked the third question
than they don't and similarly for the
rest now overall we see that they agree
more than half the time so this is true
no matter how you decide what answers
they say they're always going to break
rule three so we've just proved that our
spies can't come in with predetermined
answers but they can't communicate
either so is it just impossible to do
this task let's go back to our analogy
with the electrons remember quantum
superposition where quantum things do
all possible options until they're
observed that means our electrons are
both up and both down at the same time
till they're measured philosophically
that sounds different to having
predetermined answers but surely in
practice there's no difference between
that and if they were both up but we
just didn't know it we could give the
spies each one electron entangled to
their partners and they could measure it
in one of three directions depending on
what question they're asked that way if
they're asked the same question they
will give the same answer but again
surely this is no better than having
predetermined answers well that's where
Bell's Theorem comes in Bell showed that
if you set it up just right the spice
could use this machine to make sure they
only say the same answer half the time I
talked about how Bell's Theorem works in
detail in this video so if you're
interested check it out the main reason
it works though is because entangled
particles can affect each other even in
circumstances where no normal objects
can communicate with each other now it's
clear why you don't actually want to use
this set of because we just proved that
no other thing in the universe
besides entanglement can account for you
guys obeying these three criteria so if
the enemy know
that your spies did they'd know you
schemed against them so that's my
solution but more interestingly let's
talk about yours a whole bunch of you
immediately recognize that this is based
on Bell's Theorem that's awesome but I'm
also really pleased that most of you
didn't and instead you tried to answer
the question just using logic what
impressed me was that many of you derive
the impossibility part yourself or got
the main idea of the proof amongst
physicists Bell's Theorem
is notorious for being difficult maybe
that's because it's too scary with its
machines and measurement axes so I was
trying to take the physics context out
and see what you guys did with it and I
was hugely impressed by how earnestly
you guys tackled this problem also how
creatively I especially enjoyed reading
some of the backstories you gave for the
spies and their enemies anyway I was
planning on going through individual
solutions but while there were so many
instead if you don't understand why your
solution does or doesn't work please
leave a comment here about it and I'll
try get back to you thank you again for
participating I hope you know that this
wasn't about getting it right it was to
show you that you already have the tools
and the capability to tackle serious
physics problems on your own so to
everyone who participated well done